il y a quelques semaines des chercheurs
anglais ont réussi à reproduire la voix
d'un scribe momifié depuis 3000 ans pour
cela ils ont reconstitué son canal vocal
une partie de l'organisme qui va de la
glotte aux lèvres et voilà ce que ça
donne quand on parle quand on chante on
fait vibrer de l'air l'air est expulsé
de nos poumons au moment où on expire au
passage il fait vibrer deux petits
muscles situés où sont menées dans la
trachée baptisé à tort des cordes
vocales vous le voyez ses muscles n'ont
rien à voir avec des cordes cette
vibration entraîne la compression et la
détente des molécules qui constitue
l'air cette libération se propage
ensuite dans la gorge et dans la bouche
des résonateurs qui vont façonner la
voix allez on réécoute le scribe vous
vous rendez compte
une dictée confiné depuis 3000 ans
qu'elle capsule
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également revoir les vidéos
précédentes en cliquant sur le côté
droit
j'en fais une nouvelle chaque jour et
pour être sûr de ne rater aucune et bien
abonnez vous et activer la petite cloche
et n'oubliez pas je me confie n'est ni
en reste en lien à demain